[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
the Fourier transform and Fourier series
and how you can use these to solve
partial differential equations and I
want to give an example of the heat
equation so this is actually how Fourier
devised the Fourier transform was to
solve the heat equation so I'm going to
work through this a little bit now and
we're gonna have some other examples
later to go a little bit more into
depths on how to derive the heat
equation how the Fourier transform is an
eigen decomposition or a change of
coordinates into eigenvectors of the
laplacian operator that's in the heat
equation we'll talk about that later
we'll also have a bunch of MATLAB and
Python codes where we simulate these
PDEs
using the Fourier transform using the
fast Fourier transform which is how you
do this on a computer but here I just
want to walk you through kind of some of
the steps that are involved in analyzing
a PDE using the Fourier transform okay
and so how do I want to think about this
so I'm going to have I guess I should
write down some problems so the heat
equation we're gonna say is U T equals
some positive constant I'm gonna call
this alpha squared because I don't want
to have like negative heat diffusion u
xx
okay so this is a 1d heat equation this
is the 1d heat equation and the way you
can think about this is that you have
kind of an infinite maybe like a thin
piece of metal a 1d piece of metal with
some initial heat distribution then
we're gonna call you at X at time 0 you
of all of space at time 0 is my initial
temperature distribution okay and as X
goes to plus and minus infinity this
thing is gonna have to die off to zero
otherwise this would have infinite heat
energy which is non-physical okay so I
have some initial temperature
distribution I'm assuming that that
temperature eventually will die out to 0
at plus or minus infinity so that I
don't have infinite temperature infinite
heat energy in this thin 1d piece of
metal and this is my my governing
equation this is the heat equation okay
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to Fourier transform this this
equation and we're gonna show that it's
actually very easy to solve this this is
a partial differential equation in space
and time but when we Fourier transform
we're gonna get a simple ordinary
differential equation out okay that's
what I'm going to show you so let's do
this and I just want to remind you that
remember U is a function of X and T and
so if I Fourier transform this function
of X and T I'm Fourier transforming I
can choose space or time but I'm gonna
Fourier transform with respect to space
okay because space is my my coordinate
that goes to negative infinity and
positive infinity usually we think of
time as starting at zero and going to
positive infinity so space is kind of a
two sided infinite variable and so if I
Fourier transform with respect to space
I'm gonna get this u hat of Omega and T
good okay and of course remember that
the derivative of U with respect to X if
I take F of U X so DDX of you then I'll
get an i Omega u hat and if I take f of
u X X I'll get two I Omega is out I'll
get an I Omega squared which is a minus
Omega squared u hat okay good so that's
that nice property of the Fourier
transform that the Fourier transform of
derivatives is just I Omega times that
Fourier transform good so now what we're
gonna do is we're going to transform
this this u PDE and u using these
Fourier transform rules okay and maybe
I'll be super explicit this u hat is
still a function of Omega and T so my
time variable didn't change remember I'm
just Fourier transforming with respect
to space okay so that's what we're gonna
do we're going to Fourier transform this
with respect to space so we're gonna
Fourier transform and what we're gonna
get is D DT of U hat
equals now the Fourier transform of u xx
is just minus Omega squared u hat so I'm
gonna have a minus Omega squared alpha
squared u hat good and this is really
nice this is a function of Omega and T
and this is a function of Omega and T
this is no longer a partial differential
equation this is just an ordinary
differential equation with a time
derivative equal sum function and for
each Omega if I lock in Omega this is
just a function of time and it's a
normal ordinary differential equation in
time for each fixed Omega okay that's
the key here so now what we're gonna do
is we're going to solve this OD e in
time that's actually quite simple so I
can say that u hat of Omega at some
future time T is just e to the minus
Omega squared alpha squared T times u
hat of Omega at an initial time T naught
this is just how you solve a know de you
at some time T is e to the lambda T
times u at time not at time 0 ok this is
just the normal way of solving an OD e
and just think about how much simpler
this is than solving the full PDE right
you could use I don't know some PDE
method to solve this but by Fourier
transforming we just get an OD e for
every fixed value of Omega so we get a
family of OD es for every Omega and this
is the solution ok now this is kind of
cool this is a Gaussian function ok this
is a maybe at all I'll change my colors
a little bit so this is a Gaussian
kernel so a Gaussian and essentially
what we can do this is the product u hat
at Omega and T is the product of two
functions of Omega okay so this is like
f hat and G hat and remember if we
inverse Fourier transform f hat times G
hat the inverse Fourier transform is
just the convolution of the two inverse
Fourier transforms okay and that's what
we're gonna do now
what we actually want we don't want the
solution in 48 coordinates we want the
solution in in physical coordinates we
want to know what the final time heat
distribution is and so what we're going
to do is we're going to map back to
original coordinates we're going to say
U of X and T is equal to the inverse
Fourier transform of U hat
Omega NT which is going to be equal to
the inverse Fourier transform of this
Gaussian this e to the minus Omega
squared alpha squared T convolution
integral with the inverse Fourier
transform of U hat Omega naught but this
u hat Omega naught is just the Fourier
transform of my initial temperature
distribution so the inverse Fourier
transform of this initial temperature
distribution and Fourier coordinates is
just my initial temperature distribution
in regular space coordinates so
convolution with U of X at time 0 my
initial condition and here's where it
gets kind of interesting so the inverse
Fourier transform of a Gaussian is
another Gaussian that's a property you
can derive using the Fourier transform
integral you can plug this in and show
that your inverse Fourier transform is
another Gaussian so this is essentially
another Gaussian in X and T I'm just
going to write a Gaussian in X and T
convolution with my initial condition my
initial condition ok and what's
interesting is that as time goes on
again you'll have to work this out I
probably can actually write out roughly
what this Gaussian looks like the
Scotian is something like 1 over 2 alpha
square root of pi T e to the minus x
squared over 4 alpha squared T something
like that and so what this means is that
as time goes on as as time
gets bigger and bigger as time goes on
with this initial condition this Goshen
gets more and more and more spread out
so I'll just write this out okay so I
start out with a very very sharp
gaussian and as time goes on this couch
in spreads out and gets fatter and
fatter and fatter and more and more
diffuse okay so this is called a
diffusion kernel diffusion kernel okay
and essentially what we're doing is
we're taking our initial condition and
we're convolving it with a diffusion
kernel so we take this diffusion kernel
and we slide it across and take the dot
product and we smooth out this
distribution it gets smoother and
smoother and smoother and the more time
passes the wider this diffusion kernel
gets and the more it smoothes out the
features in my initial temperature
distribution so even if I had an initial
temperature distribution that had some
big spikes in it very very rapidly
this Gaussian is going to smooth those
out and blend them into their neighbors
okay so that's what the heat equation
does that's why it's called the heat
equation or the diffusion equation is
essentially it takes initial conditions
initial distributions and it convolve
z-- them with a gaussian that gets
fatter and fatter in time okay and
that's particularly easy to see when we
work in the Fourier transform
coordinates okay so we Fourier transform
in space our PDE becomes an Eau de
that's much much easier to work with so
we can solve that OD using you know
standard methods and Odie's and what we
now see is that in the Fourier transform
domain it's the product of our initial
condition with a Gaussian okay and when
we inverse Fourier transform we get
another Gaussian that's convolution
integral with our initial condition and
that Gaussian just gets spread and
spread and spread out more and more and
more over time so that final time as
time goes to infinity this distribution
will eventually go and get spread out to
zero okay everything will cool out to
infinity
okay so just one example of how you can
use the Fourier transform to
work with PDS to turn PDEs into Odie's
we're also going to use the fast fourier
transform this is like the regular
integral fourier transform we're going
to use the fast Fourier transform to do
this on in computers to solve these
numerically ok so we're going to do a
lot of that in matlab and python alright
thank you